welcome back
Americans struggle to fill their cart as
Hunter sells his crappy art
I guess it's time for
[Music]
um
and to think Gene Nelson does that whole
thing in his closet it's amazing
Hunter Biden's art dealer calls him
quote one of the most consequential
artists in this Century which is weird
because when has Hunter actually dealt
with consequences
his idea of taking responsibility is
having sex with his dead brother's wife
and then abandoning his laptop like it's
one of his own kids
you know when somebody's name is George
but as an s on it Duke say Jorge or
Georges anyway
anyway
George's Burgess
has been selling Hunter's Finger
Paintings for reported half a million
dollars each but we still don't know the
buyer's identities or the actual price
tags and he won't say if he'll disclose
the names to Congress so Hunter keeps
cashing in but like a woman standing in
front of his dear old dad
Americans are feeling the pinch
a new poll shows four in ten that's 40
cat say they're worse off financially
since Joe Biden has become president
look at those numbers
made you look
luckily he's only been president for two
years
another survey says 82 percent of middle
income households have cut back on how
much they save or Worse have dipped into
their savings to make ends meet much
like David and with inflation through
the roof one in five Shoppers are buying
groceries at Dollar stores where the
Best Buy dates are in Roman numerals
so as the country goes broke it's
amazing Biden doesn't get more credit
since he's got a lot of things to Tout
he's got a lot of things to tell
why do you think that it has not
penetrated the American public well
these things don't sell themselves
[Laughter]
these things don't sell themselves well
if they sold themselves Hunter's penis
would be inside them
[Laughter]
I know
but we use the medically legitimate term
therefore it doesn't get bleeped
a little secret to you fledgling talk
show hosts out there all right what say
you Joe yeah yeah your credit where
credit is too that's right Chuck's right
Chuck Todd I like that guy Chuck
Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck
wagon
remember Chuck Wagon riding around the
kitchen floor yeah
nice ride shotgun on Chuck Wagon not a
joke true story
there's Bad Dudes
Corn Pop you want to board the Chuck
Wagon denied yeah
Brian there's a weird I have this weird
feeling okay like when you ask people
are they better off or worse off I was
going to ask you that but then I realize
that we have so many things now in our
lives that are cheap and take up a lot
of time do we notice that we're going
downhill if we were on Tick Tock if
we're on Instagram if if I mean in this
I grew up in the 70s in the 80s I've
been through that like you know when
things are bad because you had nothing
else to compare you had nothing else to
do that's right we're so distracted now
that you can you can look at the eggs in
your fridge and say oh my gosh I can't
afford those then oh my gosh what can I
watch over here for the next 20 minutes
yes but think about this we're actually
doing stories on people in Suburban
America buying chicken coops and
chickens right because they can't afford
the eggs you're telling me that life's
gotten better and in your little square
plot in the backyard you're going to put
a chicken coop I I think where our
measurements are a little off here which
is why Buddha Jazz says well these
things don't sell themselves actually
they they do if inflation's not double
digits the things sell themselves when
you can't afford them they don't sell
themselves it's interesting another
survey said are you better or worse off
and 90 percent said better but those
were the chickens right
those were the of course they've got
they're moving everywhere cat they they
get their eggs at premium prices uh let
me ask you if you notice okay not in if
you have you noticed based on financial
pressures or whatnot your life is better
or worse
in the last two years yeah
actually the other day like my husband
said to me like cat like we need to cut
back I'm like on what we don't do
anything
like on like on eating food
on my commute to work or on my commute
home from work
I don't go out I don't do anything yeah
so I would notice that the only reason I
don't is because he's the one who reads
all the credit card statements exactly
because they have numbers in them and
I'm a girl so it's not my thing
uh but if you're better off you either
like gotta raise or you're not paying
attention because whatever how much
money you're making it's just not as
worth what it would have been before and
I don't also blame anybody for not
putting like giving credit to Biden I
mean just take politics out of it all
you have to do is watch him talk for
like a couple of seconds and you're like
there's no way he can be that involved
in anything no right it's like when you
thank your little baby cousins kid for
getting you a Christmas present yeah
you're like sweetheart thank you so much
you know they had nothing to do with it
yeah exactly
no it's true but your point is you know
what inflation is an invisible thing but
it's a real thing Emily it's a tax I
mean like basically if you're making if
you're making 80 grand a year you're
probably actually in real terms making
you take out the taxes you're probably
making 35 000 a year because then
because everything goes up in price ten
percent but you're also getting taxes
taken out I know I'm using numbers Emily
foreign
I'm just quoting cat
um yeah the I mean the numbers you
quoted are definitely accurate under
Biden's America
um and taxes disproportionately affect
the poor the the you know lower classes
um The Smelly people
inflation disproportionately affects the
middle class so that statistic that you
read in the beginning the 8 out of 10
American households that have dipped
into their savings or that have stopped
saving because of Biden's America that
happened in three months it wasn't over
two years that poll was over they said
over a three-month period of time and
that just goes to show that no matter
what Comfort level you have whatever
cushion you have that you tell yourself
yes this is secure and I've done this
financially responsibly and this will
take care of my family something as as
unpredictable as the avian flu mixed
with this incompetent president's
administration's decisions is what can
obliterate your savings it's what can
obliterate your cushion and all of a
sudden you live in fear and that's why
when he was asked about it on Friday and
he responded by swearing at the reporter
he can't even handle one question
because he can't get in the trenches
with Americans and say this must be
really hard let me hear what you have to
say let me acknowledge your pain instead
he's just calling his son Hunter which
by the way the FBI in concert the doj
underwent an almost two-year
investigation I think in addition with
the Senate because of the money
laundering and the rampant illicit
behavior that goes on within the private
art dealership and acquisition industry
so for him to think for them to to try
to force feed us yet again a gas
lighting of nothing to see here he's
just a genius and his art is amazing
absolutely not we should know who is
buying his art because nine times out of
ten guaranteed it's either someone from
China or maybe a certain town in Ukraine
all right well she snuck the avian flu
in there David I'm not wrong no I know
that's scary the avian flu is a big deal
and as you know are you are you now at
Dollar Stores uh because of the because
of the implosion of Western razor and
you're a comedy no implosion I mean I'm
the only guy dropping prices is the kind
of the thing you know I'm not there
my blades are my blades are five cents
you know I mean I don't know how much
lower I can go
but inflation is crazy I mean I was at
Nordstrom's went to Nordstrom's just to
buy a sweater yeah turns out it's
cheaper to spend the winter in Barbados
I mean
you want to end on that note you think
tie note
yeah it was
I mean you could go to another joke but
it might not be as good
what do you guys think cheers
what no no I don't know okay hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else